CIRCULAR PARTING FROM
STENOGRAPHERS IN THE MEDIA MOB.
BOLSTERING THEIR LIVES PRETTY
HERE WITH A REACTION TO THAT IN
THE BIG DEVELOPMENT SURROUNDING
HUNTER BIDEN, SENATE JUDICIARY
CHAIRMAN, LINDSEY GRAHAM AND
BEFORE WE GET TO THE HEARING,
LET'S START WITH TODAY'S
HEARINGS.
OH, LET'S SEE, THE PRESIDENT
SAID TO ME, NO EQUATED PRO OR
QUO.
WHEN DID YOU UKRAINE MENTOR,
THERE'S NO QUO THE DID NOT GET
IT, AND IT'S A CHECKMATE, GAME
OF ART, GAMES THAT MATCH.
>> AND SONDLAND SAID TODAY, IT
WAS AN OPEN SECRET, EVERYBODY
UNDERSTOOD THAT THE NO MEETING
AND UNLESS THEY OPENED UP THE
INVESTIGATION WITH THE BIDENS.
IF IT IS NOT OPEN AND THAT WELL
KNOWN, WHY DID HE NOT TESTIFY
THE FIRST TIME HE WAS UNDER OATH
WEEKS AGO.
WHY DID NOT THE VICE PRESIDENT
KNOW IT, AND WHY DID VOLKER KNOW
IT, WHY DID THAT THE PRESIDENT
ANNOYS?
THE ONLY PART TESTIMONY ABOUT
THE PRESIDENCY WAS, I DON'T WANT
ANYTHING AND THERE'S NO QUID PRO
QUO.
I CAN TELL AND EVERYBODY IN THE
WORLD.
DONALD TRUMP WOULD NOT GIVE THE
UKRAINE A DIME OF A TODAY UNLESS
MYSELF, RON JOHNSON, ROB PORTMAN
AND OTHERS PUSH THE ISSUE.
I WAS WILLING TO VOTE TO TURN
THE AID BACK ON TO THE 11TH
BECAUSE AS I THOUGHT THE
UKRAINIANS NEITHER THE AID AND I
TRUSTED THAT THE NEW
PRESIDENT.
THEN, ONLY THEN, THEY TURNED THE
AID OFF.
>> Sean: BY THE WAY, AND I
MEAN, THE PRESIDENT IS CLEAR.
WITH EVERYBODY.
YOU KNOW WHY HE WOULDN'T DO THE
PRINT QUOTE PRO
QUID PRO QUO, IT WAS NOT OE
QUID PRO QUO, IT WAS NOT O,
WELL-KNOWN, WHY DID YOU NOT
MENTION THAT THE FIRST TIME
YOU TESTIFIED?
WHAT HAPPENS BETWEEN THE FIRST
DAY HE TESTIFIED AND TODAY, THE
BUSINESS IS BEING DESTROYED AND
HIS FAMILY IS BEING HARASSED.
HE FOUND IT TODAY, HE'S TRYING
TO GET THE MONKEY OFF HIS BACK
AND IT MAKES NO SENSE THAT HE
KNOWS IT NOW AND DID NOT KNOW IT
THEN.
IF IT WAS THAT OBVIOUS, THE
WHOLE THING IS BECOMING A JOKE.
WE WANT NO QUID PRO QUO, THE
FIRST PERSON THAT EVER TALK TO
THE PRESIDENT, AND THE PRESIDENT
SAID HIS EXCULPATORY.
WELL, IT'S IT OPENS SECRET MEDIA
IS TIED TO ACTIONS WE HAVE A
LETTER SAYING POINTING TO THE
CONTRARY.
AND NO PRECONDITIONS.
AM  EMMA WRITES, SENATOR?
>> THE VICE PRESIDENT SAID I
NEVER TALK TO SONDLAND'S ABOUT
ANY CONDITIONS ABOUT ANY MEETING
OR THE AGENT.
VOLKER SAID THERE'S NO CRITICAL
QUOTE.
AND THE FIRST TIME HE TESTIFIED,
HE'S MAKING UP BECAUSE HE GOT
THE HILL BEATING OUT OF HIM.
>> Sean: YOUR LAWYER AND
PROSECUTOR, A PERIOD HANG ON,
WHEN JOE BIDEN SAID, YOU'RE NOT
GETTING THE MILLION, FIRE HIM
AND SON OF A DBA, THEY DID IT.
AND THEY PAID MILLIONS.
HIS NAME IS USED WITH OBAMA
SECRETARY AND, HUNTER WORKS AND
PLEASE STOP INVESTING US.
>> I GUESS WHAT HE'S PAID MILLI
>> I GUESS WHAT HE'S PAID MILLN
>> I GUESS WHAT HE'S PAID MILL.
WE GET TO THE BOTTOM OF THE
TUBE, SIR?
ON 2015, AMBASSADOR OF UKRAINE,
HE MADE THE SPEECH ABOUT
CORRUPTION AND HE WANTED THE
PART GENERAL PROSECUTOR TO BE
MORE AGGRESSIVE.
THE ONE BEING NAMED A SLEAZEBAG,
AND WHAT'S THE NAME OF THE
COMPANY?
>> Sean: BURISMA.
>> THE ONE PERSON THAT I
MENTIONED IN 2015, TO BE
CORRUPT, WITH THE PRESIDENT OF
THE GAS COMPANY.
THE SAME GUY FINALLY GETS
INVESTIGATED BY THE PROSECUTOR,
THAT THEY REWARD THE PROSECUTOR
SAYING, WELL DONE, THIS IS WHAT
YOU WE WANT YOU TO DO.
IF THEY FIRED THE GUY FOR DOING
TOO MUCH.
>> Sean: SENATOR, HE TALKED
ABOUT THE CALLS, BIDEN AND
POROSHENKO, THE FORMER PRESIDEN
PRESIDENT.
HOW THAT WERE RELEASING
TRANSCRIPTS, ANY CHANCE WE CAN
EVER GET THOSE?
>> ON FAIRBURY THE SECOND, THE
PROSECUTOR RAIDED THE HOUSE OF
THE GAS COMPANY, FEBRUARY THE
FOURTH, HE MAKES THE
ANNOUNCEMENT, HE CALLS THE
STATE DEPARTMENT AND ON THE
11TH, THE 11TH, THE 18TH,
19TH OF FEBRUARY, JOE BIDEN
CALLS THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UKRAINE.
A MONTH LATER, THEY FIRE THE
PROSECUTOR AND THIS IS THE SAME
GUY THAT WAS URGED TO TAKE
ACTION AGAINST THE GAS COMPANY
PRESIDENT OF THE AMERICAN
AMBASSADOR AND 2015.
THIS DOES NOT ADD UP.
WHAT WAS THE PHONE CALL ABOUT?
WHY WOULD YOU WANT TO FIRE THE
GUY AFTER YOU YOU PROSECUTED THE
PERSON YOU SAID WAS THE DIRTIEST
PERSON ALL OF THE UKRAINE?
>> Sean: OKAY.
YOU MENTIONED TO ME THAT YOU
HAVE A LETTER GOING OUT.
>> YES.
>> Sean: WHAT'S THE LETTER GO
TO MIKE ABOUT?
>> I WANT TO KNOW IF THERE'S ANY
TRANSCRIPT OR READOUTS AND THE
PRESIDENT OF THE RAIDED, AND THE
GAS COMPANY PRESIDENT'S HOUSE.
AFTER THE RAID, HUNTER BIDEN
KICKS IN, AND HUNTER BIDEN'S
BUSINESS PARTNER, JOHN KERRY,
AND ADVISES HIM ON THREE
OCCASIONS TO MAKE A PHONE CALL
TO THE PRESIDENT OF THE UKRAINE
AND GOES OVER THERE IN MARCH AND
THEY FIRE THE GUY.
AND THIS IS THE SAME MAN OF THE
AMBASSADOR WANTED TO INVESTIGATE
IN 2015.
WHAT HAPPEN HERE, IS, HUNTER
BIDEN WAS ON THE BOARD AND THAT
CHANGED EVERYTHING.
>> Sean: THE LETTER GOES OUT
TOMORROW TO THE SECRETARY OF
STATE MIKE POMPEO, --
>> NEVER CALLED ME.
I WANT TO KNOW FROM MIKE POMPEO,
AND HE RECORDS THAT THE
VICE PRESIDENT TALKED ABOUT.
WHY WERE YOU CALLING THE
RESIDENCE AFTER?
RELEASED THEM!
>> Sean: RELEASE THEM!
>> INSTEAD OF CONGRATULATING THE
PROSECUTOR FOR GOING AFTER THE
DIRTIEST GUY IN THE UKRAINE, THE
END OF FIRING HIM.
IT DIDN'T DO ANYTHING WITH THE
FACT THAT HUNTER BIDEN WAS ON
THE BOARD?
YOU HAVE TO REMEMBER THAT THE
VICE PRESIDENT SON WAS SERVING
ON THE BOARD THAT WAS RUN BY THE
DIRTIEST GUY ACCORDING TO THE
UKRAINE ACCORDING TO OUR OWN
AMBASSADOR IN 2015.
>> Sean: YOU HAVE ON SEPTEMBER 1
>> Sean: YOU HAVE ON SEPTEMBER T
>> Sean: YOU HAVE ON SEPTEMBER H
>> Sean: YOU HAVE ON SEPTEMBER C
>> Sean: YOU HAVE ON SEPTEMBER M
>> Sean: YOU HAVE ON SEPTEMBER E
>> Sean: YOU HAVE ON SEPTEMBER T
INSPECTOR GENERAL FOR THE
COMMITTEE.
>> I'M HOPING WE GET A NUMBER OF
DAYS AND NOT ON THE FRIDAY, A
DUMP.
YOU WILL GET THE REPORT.
>> Sean: DECEMBER THE NINTH.
IT'S LOCKED.
>> IT'S LOCKED.
>> Sean: OKAY, THAT'S A
MONDAY, WE WILL BE IN YOUR
CHAMBERS ON MONDAY.
>> THIS WAS A GOOD DAY, AND IT
MAKES NO SENSE --
>> Sean: AND MAKE SENSE, IF
YOU DID NOT LIKE THE ELECTION
RESULTS OF 2016 IT MAKES SENSE,
IF YOU DID NOT GET FROM THE
FBI'S INVESTIGATION, THE INTEL
HOUSE INVESTIGATION AND THE
BIPARTISAN OF WHAT YOU WANTED,
SURE, IT MAKES SENSE.
LET'S MOVE THIS WAY NOW, I MAKE